sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
with Chef Doran Peterson at sticky
fingers in Washington DC we have
Challenger we're creating a dish that
will make 16 sweeter chef Peterson has
prepared a list of essential ingredients
to do just that they are vegan cake
vixens because that is what you do when
you want to celebrate your birthday and
impress michael scofield ocol Estoril
shake and bake baby 16 candles 16
candles it came out in 1984 it was John
Hughes first movie he ever directed feel
like it almost invented the 80s it
almost did it certainly stands for the
80s almost as much as any other movie
you could think of um you know I've seen
this movie a handful of times um the one
thing I remember most is how freaking
young Anthony Michael Hall is yes he's
15 or 16 and so this sort of introduced
us to my Ringwald she was in fact a life
before that if you were a hardcore fact
a life person he knew this you knew her
but this sort of introduced the world to
her she became America's Sweetheart
basically for he did yes he was she was
America's Sweetheart for a long time
yeah Oh at the point where it's all
shocking she's so far out of the
limelight now right it is I think she
must have made a conscious decision I
don't like this and also and this is the
terrible thing about you know being that
cute you know like it girl you know
whatever once you start growing up and
don't look like that anymore
then you people stop writing roles that
you know that feature that or whatever
[Music]
there's a point in that movie where Jake
Ryan the big heartthrob Phil Bethany
Michael Hall like well she's drunk you
can just go ahead and do whatever you
want she won't know
I gotta admit having seen this recently
I was like oh my jaw drop I was like you
could never ever nor what would you do
this today then just the probably racist
foreign exchange student yeah long Duk
dong who is introduced with a gong every
time he shows up what's happening the
hot stuff um I think that's kind of
racist you know I've read the the
screenwriter says that wasn't in the
script but yeah well he was mad about
like he didn't appreciate the gong yeah
I think even if you take the gall away
no it's so it's still kind of racist
well Kathy you speak from that like you
know that's tilted whatever as men as
long at all yeah long that does naming
him that alone is kind of insulting I
will say that he Getty Watanabe plays
the kid plays the character he does like
do things that are like a little bit
more than like this typical racist
character I mean he's not like I don't
know like Mickey Rooney and Breakfast at
Tiffany's or something like that you'll
just some of me
you must have a key mate buddies you
know he he falls in love with a girl and
you know he's and he's just he just
seems like a normal college student but
all these things that they keep doing
with his name and the song and all the
other title stuff that kind of DAT yes
you
[Music]
taystee hi
doing all right whoo give you two forks
you're just gonna get it like that okay
okay that's all good to me what does it
say happy birthday Samantha Mantha okay
we were speculating my serve birthday
cake in order of the movies theme and
the extra irony is today is actually my
birthday
any idea and it just worked out
perfectly
yeah so I'm gonna get to Hamburg AJ oh
my birthday I just use my fingers or one
minute I'm on life yeah no not kind of
like this is very technical work
Cantonese so this is our vanilla cake
mm-hmm with a lemon curd filling oh you
really are excited oh my goodness
it's excellent of course it is oh my god
how many times have you seen the movie
maybe through cutscene yeah I was doing
a couple times really I was nine when it
came out yes I was 12
okay so that was just like you know it's
probably the perfect age oh my gosh it's
no yeah it's like the big kids and
they're so cool and on high school and
I'm not quite of love but then it you
know turns into love over a cake and
were you also in love with Jake Ryan I
mean I'm still in love with chicken
still love them yeah how do you feel
about my Anthony Michael Hall because we
found out researching for this Jim Carey
dried out the devil really he would have
been super young but would have been a
completely different movie I think yeah
I mean Anthony Michael Hall was great I
mean at the time now you know
I haven't seen anyone I'm not sure what
he's doing anymore wonder what he's up
to these days
Oh maybe shopping at an AT&T store this
is lemon in the middle yeah
lemon curd we don't use eggs we use
different different binders it doesn't I
mean I'll be honest it doesn't face at
all
like different than a normal cake it
doesn't taste like I think there's a
vegan option well I think there's a
perception from people outside the vegan
world or marketplace that that it all
tastes weird I think that it's come a
long way I think that when I was younger
before sixteen Candles came out and I
would go to alternative or healthier
bakeries that were associated with non
dairy and egg free you know that's that
was health food and that's not what
we're doing
um we're definitely taking a different
angle while it is healthier that's not
the main focus that we have it really is
showing people that you can have a
plant-based diet and choose plant-based
options in a way that is still really
fun well I don't know what else to say
about it besides the fact that I love it
it's very tasty you seriously have to
kiss over the cake I mean you have to do
the closing scene it's the closing scene
Who am I gonna kiss mm-hmm well my wife
would be too happy about that only he
would be too happy about that
thanks to Doron for the amazing cake
make sure you head on over to the
community table channel where she can
fill you in with vegan baking knowledge
and you can hear more from all the other
chefs we got to hang out thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time on
movie recipe
[Music]